house Cumbres my spare time today
actually yesterday Kim Kardashian
released these ridiculous photographs
calling it break the internet and let's
be honest we're all doing her a favor by
making fun of her because she just wants
all the attention I thought it could be
fun to play around with some photo shops
I feel inspired
so I studious alright um I don't know
what happened
I mean allahö shocked the asses
beautiful face too
she has very nice facial figures I gotta
say guess it's gonna have nightmares
tonight I'm as shocked as her but oh wow
this one is nice too I got a weird idea
[Laughter]
this is so [__] beautiful oh no what
happened I'm so fat we are those buck
ads yes yes they are but ads what the
[__] delete this don't tell me what to
go I don't know what's wrong with me
either don't don't even worry about it
what have I done the best thing ever
someone take Photoshop away from pity
pun you're breaking my erection before I
did YouTube I applied for a job in it at
a place where I would do Photoshop I'm
so glad I didn't get that job
mmm I'm so hungry now
all right Prez they like enjoy this
video thank you for watching I really
appreciate it and as always stay awesome
bros
[Music]